head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts let me P the
story here from Politico Trump allies
and Maga luminaries move to kill off the
Haley for VP Buzz Haley's rise as
prompted speculation she'd be a logical
running mate for Trump this is fake news
this is an absolutely fake story and I'm
willing to bet that uh these two people
who wrote it fabricated it through
clever manipulation what I mean by that
is you take a morsel of truth and you
can make it mean whatever you want it to
mean you can make it convey whatever you
want it to convey take a look at this
the fervent effort to kill off Haley's V
Buzz before it truly takes off has come
from the former as the former un
Ambassador in next South Carolina
governor is gaining momentum in the
Republican primary it is prompted
speculation she'd be a logical Choice as
a running mate for Trump who has
maintained a wide polling lead blah blah
blah her rise has caught the attention
of the former president who has recently
quizzed people outside his campaign for
their impressions of Haley according to
three people familiar with the
conversation quote what do you think of
Nikki Trump had asked It's Not Unusual
for Trump to survey donors outside adver
outside advisers and members of his Mar
Lago Resort on Personnel matters he's
also blah blah blah blah blah what do
they say um he pressed allies for the
impressions of other Republicans etc etc
but Haley has been the subject of his
most recent Focus Haley's polling surge
has alarmed some staunch Trump trump
confidants who are acutely aware the
former president pays close attention to
survey dat data Etc Etc so they're
referencing uh during a phone
conversation with one Ally about Haley
Trump indicated that he was aware of the
criticisms of her but nonetheless wanted
to get this person's take of the former
Ambassador according to a person
familiar with the call here's what
likely really happened Donald Trump
probably called someone and said yeah
I'm hearing a lot of people in the media
talking about it we how how are you
doing these journalists then say the
reason why Trump is not quoted here if
someone truly came to them three people
apparently familiar with this call
you'd think they would go Donald Trump
said in fact there is an earlier quote
what do you think of Nikki Trump had
asked where's the rest of what he said
why because they they don't want to get
sued right so the I always explain this
to people the media will lie when they
ask you for when they ask you for a
quote no matter what you say they will
find a way to make it the narrative they
want for example a journalist contacts
James o'keef says we write a story about
you it's a profile I'm curious what's
your take on dogs
and then James says I love dogs I think
dogs are fantastic who doesn't love dogs
and they'll go o that's a quote we can't
run I got an idea when asked about
whether James O'Keefe liked dogs he
asked an intriguing question seemingly
confused indicating in fact he may not
actually like dogs at all when they
don't use quotes they're lying to you
well this like what do you think of
Haley they don't say really anything
other than it's on this supposed call I
mean it could you could easily pull it
from like a rally like what if Trump
walked out of rally and was like what do
you guys think of Nikki Haley and they
all booed right like this of anything
it's so Random Trump could have been on
the phone with Steve Bannon who knows
and then he's like yeah I saw what
Tucker said about Haley as if anyone
actually cares what do you think about
Haley as if anyone's going to ask that
question and they run that quote
specifically out of context to make it
seem like Donald Trump actually wants do
think of Haley she I think she's about
to cancel her campaign said Trump he
might have said he might have said uh a
bunch of criticism about her what do you
think about her the like I don't know
and he's like all right the way I look
at this is a a journalism professor said
many years ago he said the way you deal
with these is every time they use these
so this is anonymously sourced here
according to people familiar with the
matter the way I see it is it you need
more of your stories to produce actual
evidence like over 51% should be
documents or video but this is like the
New York Times is usually 95 to 100%
anonymously material so it's like taking
money out of an ATM I have to deposit
into my bank account because I'm
withdrawing upon my own journalistic
credibility if I'm going to say trust me
by virtue of the decree that I'm to be
trusted I Tim's right I have no reason
to trust those two guys that story I'll
give you I'll give you a a an example of
what may have happened let's say that
quote from Trump is real so Trump's on
the phone uh after uh the last GOP
debate and he goes man Ron's campaign is
not doing too well uh I'm seeing he's
down in the polls and then they're like
yep he he is crashing and burning and
then Trump goes I think they're all
crashing and burning what do you think
about Haley they take that quote and
turn it into Donald Trump was curious
about Haley as a VP pick because he
asked what do you think about Haley it
could have been in the context of him
mocking the failure of other campaigns
we don't know and I get this emails all
the time the very last second or even
like while they're publishing the story
they send me the New York Times sends me
this whole thing and I I call them up on
the phone and record it and they hang up
the phone I'm trying I mean I well
here's a tactic that you should do if
you ever get asked for comp by the media
um uh publish your statement to your
entire audience before they go to air
their story that there's nothing they
can do because you've made it clear okay
World here is my response now I have a a
pretty large following many people don't
but that's what what Trump could do but
I I think the challenge I agree but the
challenge is Politico knows our audience
doesn't care about political articles
that's true and the people who read
political are lowi information
individuals no Tim your point about the
the World being segmented where you're
only playing to your audience is a very
good point and I and I get that it's not
just only to to your audience it's you
know the the the side that we are on is
not the quote unquote right you can call
whatever you want I don't think it is I
I think it's just good and evil true and
false at this point yes agreed they call
you right-wing but you don't come out
and and and Advocate policy no never
you're like here's a here's a politician
saying a thing and they're like aha he's
rightwing it's like hold on if he was
coming out saying I'm a oppos to these
policies in favor of these policies so
vote for this person I have opinions on
politics all day every day yeah so if
they want to accuse me of something fine
I get it but but I think it is the Liars
the top down control and the ignorant
versus those who want freedom
meritocracy honesty truth Etc yeah I try
to keep it I try to keep it very factual
actually there's plenty of facts to
there's plenty of factually things say
but that that that's fascinating kind of
I love this sort of master class and
going through an article and one of the
things that they also do is they'll
they'll send me a they send me an
article say you please please comment
and then I'll give them a comment that's
quite material to the circumstance and
they'll say James O'Keefe did not
respond to what we was asked about well
it's like print what I want print what I
said if you really want to have fairness
which is all these journalists do but um
I I think um yeah I think it's a it's a
great exercise going through this like
you're doing I think if the journalists
maybe if they want to get comments from
now on it should be live the comments
should be live it should all be on a
chat thing on a website where it happens
in real time talk to him look you if if
if they come to you and and like again
using the dog analogy if they said um do
you support uh the working class and you
go absolutely I support the working
class instead of running your quote
they'll say Ian sarcastically mocked
working-class people and asked if he
supported them and you'll be like no I
didn't I said I supported them and
they'll be yeah sarcastically yeah I
think the age of relying on someone else
to to represent you is over man you got
to represent yourself I mean one of the
other issues is that if you feel like
you can't talk to the Press right
they'll go to the person who will feel
like they can talk to them which is
typically someone who feels like they
have a friendly relationship with the
publication so you're getting a bias
Viewpoint because someone who's like I
don't trust you you're always trying to
represent me in a negative way you're
always saying I hate the working class
whatever they're ultimately going to
pull away and so the narrative becomes
more insulated that way yeah one of the
things that they do is they they they
call themselves credible there was one
story we did so Anderson Cooper this guy
from The Washington Post Jacob bagage is
his name he literally looks like humpty
dumpy he's got his oval face and bagage
says well Anderson we're credible
journalists so they they say we're
credible credible sources so they they
rely upon this virtue that they've
assigned to the themselves that they are
credible by virtue of their own decree
that they are that way and and their
anonymously sourced stuff is permitted
to contradict incontrovertible evidence
and that's why I go back to this trust
thing it's just the experts the credible
sources and now but you're making a good
point with in is incontrovertible
evidence incontrovertible because it
could be manuf it could be a deep fate
well I think I think the issue is you're
right about verification our side will
always appreciate verification sourcing
and will seek out those they can trust
those who are willing to I hate saying
that it's our but there is a a group of
people it's a way of behavior way of
behavor values there are people who look
this is why we like Marian Williamson
and when we're grateful you came on
because she is a good person and I
believe she is an honest person she uh
openly talked about her views but she
gets her news from Bad sources not
anymore not after last night well it
improves and that's why we're grateful
she comes on but when when I when uh it
was a really amazing moment last night
when we showed Marian Williamson the
whiteness contract from the book not my
idea she almost cried she had never seen
it before and so she's getting this
narrative about banning books and she
like our Republicans are crazy but the
problem with Marian's source of
information is that she's likely hearing
secondhand opinions from someone who
watched CNN and MSNBC whereas James is
actually recording people saying the
words yeah and Publishing them she then
hears her friend go oh James O'Keefe
fabricated that video and she goes wow
then when she gets into a political
debate someone says didn't you see the
video from James O'Keefe I'm I shouldn't
say Maran but the liberal will then go
he fabricated that there are going to be
a substantial minority of people who
Minds have actually been changed like I
hired this guy named Jason Watkins he's
a professor at a ASU journalism School
Tim he teaches journalism at the kronite
school he used to be a leftist his mind
was actually change I'm not am I making
this up by my colleague people think y
that's insane there are people who
actually do change their minds and if 5%
or 1% let's just call it 1% of people
change their minds or their hearts then
then one would even argue if one person
changes their mind that you made a
difference so I don't think you need to
affect the majority of people and of
course there some people say it's fake
thing but you know all right here we go
not not being angry too is a real big
part I bet the founding fathers weren't
angry guys they strike me as like really
level-headed dudes no some of them were
super angry thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net out and we'll see you all
next
time